three two going on
hi you're listening to the dollop on the
all things comedy Network each week
Jesus I this is terrible
Dave Anthony read a story from American
history to me amigo
Gareth Reynolds who has no idea what the
topic is going to be about and why
doesn't he know because he didn't listen
when they were telling him what it was
happening in history and he wanted to
leave campus and smoke cigarettes and
you know party a lot and when teachers
would tell him to pay attention this is
gonna be important in your future he was
like no and the best part is he was
right yeah that's right he's successful
now take that teachers who the good
teachers listen or you'll do or it'll
it'll hurt you
guess what dummies nice try [ __ ]
and called it quote is jam-packed I'm
okay
sick argument
we've had some laughs haven't we really
have I've had more laughs yeah not so
much for me
Gareth we are the dollop this podcast
brought to you by fabfitfun
oh boy you know if that fit funny yeah
it's a it's a sweet box of goodies I'm
gonna describe it better than that
great get into it so it's a if you don't
know what it is it's a it's a it's a box
that you get you you sign up four times
a year you can get it it's 49 nine about
$49.99 in a box you get a full size box
of fashion beauty home fitness and
wellness products it's seasonal
sure right because you enjoy your season
you know I enjoy it when the seasons
change yes and the boxes that change
with them you're a huge fan of seasons
yes
it's full size prior fiery lava yes all
the season that's not blood
those are seasons it's a great value
these aren't tiny things these are
full-size products we we've gotten two
right yeah the ladies in their lives
have gone crazy for them yeah my wife is
now wondering when the next fabfitfun
box is coming that's what happens is I
spoiled my mother with one and then that
leads to an addiction yeah and that's
the problem and that's their problems
that's not our problem
why won't they respond to my emails you
get a there's a membership right there's
a total the retail value of the summer
box which is the next box is $320 but
you get this thing for 49 that I mean
come on
$49.99 you don't need to sell me doc I'm
selling you right now so my wife loved
it there's a poncho in there that she
still loves and she and she literally is
like these are my colors I don't know
what that means but these are her colors
know for sure those are things that you
just don't ask any questions about when
they're said all right colors yeah so
you love those colors so you get fashion
you get beauty at home
Fitness Together kinds of products in
there so sign up for fabfitfun today to
get your summer box the fabfitfun summer
box is in limited supply and these boxes
always sell out always so use a good
dollop you get $10 off your first box go
to fabfitfun com2 sign up and start
getting the box for a life well-lived
use promo code up do you get $10 off
your first box that's over $200 for
$39.99 go to fabfitfun calm and use the
code dollop you get $10 off your first
fabfitfun box boom
you're my favorite fabfitfun you I wish
you came in the box oh my god we are
also sponsored by blue apron Jesus God
you need to rethink everything you've
said so Gareth and I we we often cook
together we do oh your wife hates it we
do a blue apron night where we put on
blue aprons and we do our blue apron
nothing else this week there's some good
remember when you threw that prosciutto
and it's stuck to my buttock I do always
remember that I was like the Coppertone
kid but with ham you would probably like
this creamy pesto cavatelli with
mushrooms and spicy breadcrumbs oh I see
but I had to come
III this week and we can do the pork
trees or tacos with radishes or roasted
potatoes and go heat the cheese nice so
basically if you don't know what it is
it's leading milk it delivery service in
the US you basically look at you go to
the website you look at it you pick your
meals they come ready to be cooked it's
super easy to cook they're in already
sized portions there's a sense of
accomplishment there is and it's super
easy to do you don't have to go to the
store because I don't like going to the
store you get a two person meal plan a
family meal plan incident
blue apron is offering our listeners
their first three meals free yeah you
heard that when it comes to their let
blue apron take care of the planning and
shopping while you do the cooking and
eating you'll enjoy delicious meals like
popcorn chicken with sweet chili cabbage
sounds good you know lately I've just
been eating popcorn for dinner you can
do it make 30 minutes or less that's not
a good thing to say that's weird
so easy so it's really good every
patient every meal I've made I've
enjoyed the hell out of even the ones I
cook with Gareth it's light-hearted to
hear
remember the prosciutto buttock come on
so check out this hot I'll check out
this week's menu and get your first
three meals free at blueprint comm slash
dollop blue apron a better way to cook
nice and we're cookers mean yeah yeah
absolutely no like I'm gonna cook you
someday what does I mean I'm gonna eat
you one day and own your knowledge we're
also brought to you by and you know all
about this Casper yeah you got yourself
a sweet Casper damn right it's a sleep
brand that continues to revolutionize
its line of products to create an
exceptionally comfortable sleep
experience one night at a time that
Casper mattresses are perfectly designed
for humans engineered to soothe and
cradle your natural geometry and you got
some sweet geometry brother Dave yeah
but I will also say it's great for cats
that are maybe a little heavier than the
regular it supports it supports both a
heavy human I don't think they should
limit it I got a cats purr boom okay
next the Casper air mattresses combine
multiple supportive memory foams for a
quality sleep surface with the right
amount of both sink and bounce yeah like
it's a wink affordable prices because
Casper cuts out the middleman and sells
directly to the consumer no hassle
returns if you're not completely
satisfied free shipping and returns in
the US and Canada yeah it's all good you
what happened when you open yours up
again it was like it comes out of the
box yeah it's like yeah it's like
reanimating a person comes to life right
I've read get fifty dollars towards
select mattresses by visiting Casper
comm slash dollop and use promo code
dollop at checkout terms and conditions
apply that's Casper comm slash dollop
and promo code all for $50 toward select
mattresses and after you're done
listening to this episode's sponsored by
Casper check out
for the podcast sponsored by Casper it's
an entire podcast about Casper
circumspection diaspora now sponsored by
Casper the film announced iCloud Apple
podcast and stitcher caspere's has a
puck can we have cast I don't know but
I'm gonna listen to that because that
sounds hilarious there's gonna be I mean
have you never so what else you your
body sinks in there yeah yeah we said
that and oh we got to do an ad for
Casper actually we do Casper Casper
sponsors the Casper podcast Casper's a
mattress Dave I should promote myself
you can use promo code dollop for $10
tix on all these shows 31st of May
through June 2nd I'll be at the Tempe
improv in New Jersey June 21st through
the 23rd will be at the stress factory
laughs comedy club in Seattle June 29th
and the 30th and then I'll be at a
Dave's house for the rest of the week
please go to dollop talented cast calm
slash tour and look at tours because
we're gonna be in a lot of cities yes
we're coming to last when we announced
with Chicago but we're gonna be in
Chicago Pittsburgh Denver Cleveland
Minneapolis there's a lot of shows so
please go there and check them out see
four cities on there if your cities not
it might be on there sound
17:58 alrighty year of our Lord Jesus
Christ James Callender was born in
okay-y
when was the calendar born Dave it's not
what date it's not cool yeah it's not
cool yeah calendar all right keep going
I was born in Scotland oh very little is
known about his early years by the time
he was 24 he was an aspiring writer
living in Edinburgh so there's nothing
we have on him until 24 the other than
his last name was calendar yeah okay in
1782 he was hired as a clerk in the
bureaucratic a saison office which was a
land deed you know about that good night
I'm gonna explain this season office
yeah well you know what you're saying
earlier there's four seasons uh-huh hey
man you're cute you're already don't
tell a calendar when the seasons out ant
boy okay
it's a land deed office yeah Oh go ahead
sorry yep
for all of Scotland who owned what where
Wynette cetera he was not paid well
working there sure I mean he would write
out the land holdings of Scottish
gentlemen so the rich guys right so he'd
just be basically assessing the land of
the wealthy not even assessing just
keeping track yeah at the time voting in
Scotland was tied to land ownership so
the records kept in the season offices
were basically voting rolls also so the
rich could vote Yeah right
shocking as it should be right something
I wish I could vote could you imagine
allowed to cast a ballot oh boy
I'm dreaming again get back to work bye
sorry mum sweep sweep sweep sweep sweep
sweep why does he say why would you say
sweep because it gets awful dirty in
here when I'm keeping track of the
landowners I know but you don't have to
say sweeping just sweep oh but if I
don't see sweep I forget to do it like
now sweep sweep sweep sweep sweep sweep
sweep sweep
got to wok wok wok wok wok wok open door
with all his power with all the power
consolidated into this one off as it
obviously became insanely corrupt sure
James was described then as having quote
a complex and contradictory character he
was Scottish oh the letters he was
selling it he was self-righteous
strongly puritanical with regard to
personal morals insufferably proud with
a deep and abiding mistrust of human
nature
okay so totally just cool yeah yeah
super relaxed sure yeah that's I think
you're supposed to that's a better way
to be now though yeah I'd rather I think
you should be like that over like boy
mister you got a job for me
now you gotta be like hold a gun get a
gun we all need him at 1785 James spoke
as a representative of a group of clerks
who wanted better pay and their boss
Andrew Steele investigated for
corruption okay so he speaks for those
guys sure that didn't go well right they
normally don't they found the rich
frowned upon that yeah the person I'm
not a big fan of writing you yeah Steele
then made work a living hell for James
at one point Steele quote came over with
pistols and a bludgeon in order to
murder James well that's just not it's
not okay in the workplace well they
don't have posters up I think that back
then it was fine okay yeah you could
murder your employees in Scotland how
was work James was alright boss keeps
saying he's getting married to me you've
been killed
hey stop me again no no if we were to
translate an ape into English but he
didn't kill him but then for the next
few days Steele would walk around the
office with the guns Oh tell ya after
lunch I'm feeling like a killing yeah
today someone's getting killed he's
doing he's like a season finale for
commercial someone will die this week on
steel he's straight-up the [ __ ]
gardener from The Simpsons for the next
five years James and dirty huh he's so
he still works there for five years he's
a hostile work environment get through
it if you just realize he's not really
gonna kill you yeah I mean we've already
figured out he's not gonna kill you so
just hang in there and stick with it and
then he was fired in 1790 for not being
killed throw up early so he's now broke
he's been slandered by steel and he has
a family to support so as a writer he
had previously published two pamphlets
about Samuel Johnson sure who was a
popular intellectual in England Johnson
was not big on Scottish people okay
he insulted them and called him ignorant
the Scots did not like this [ __ ] talking
from Johnson and so when James published
his pamphlet titled deformities of
Samuel Johnson the Scottish people
really into it okay
so he put out a mean tweet yeah that's
right yes therefore these improper he's
a [ __ ] okay that was all right Dave
look we can't I I need you to just feel
free to just let it let it fly I'm not
gonna come at you okay save space okay
this isn't the internet this is you and
me I got you baby
uh it focused on Johnson's dictionary so
Johnson had written his dictionary which
was one of the first attempts to
categorize and organize English words
Wow okay so at the out before they were
all in the book yeah he'd this guy this
guy when they were scattered when you
would just beat like Scrabble was a
bigger argument but before this you
there were just words laying around and
pamphlet yeah and this guy put them all
in one book right right okay well I'm
off today you know I'm gonna go to bed
I'm really kinda walks it means tired
so James claimed the dictionary and
Johnson were both useless quote a
madness bloody dictionary in almost
every department of learning from
astronomy down to the first principles
of grammar Johnson's ignorance seems
amazing which is I word his personal
appearance cannot much recommend him his
conversation would shock the rudest
Savage I have attempted to illustrate
his entire want of general learning his
antipathy to rival merit his paralytic
reasoning his solemn trifling pedantry
Wow
yes he's now and he's there's a
thesaurus happening right yeah he
probably uses his dictionary prolly yeah
what he helpful it was to put it in the
end
I've gotta save my work I don't want to
be accused of plagiarism awkward we've
already been called deformed okay so
he's just writing the so okay so he's
baiting and also this literary style of
attack
mixing personal and professional
critiques was brand-new okay and it was
similar to the writing of Jonathan Swift
both writers writers rejected pretension
greed and pride okay so James then after
he gets fired he turns to writing for
living okay
there are lots of literary of a pamphlet
agent he did not that'll come up okay
there are lots of literary clubs in the
city but he didn't have any ins into
them luckily he received patronage from
one Lord garden stone that's right I'll
help you James that'll be your patreon
you know where I'll be in the back on
that one stone in the garden he helped
James get work with a famous lawyer and
they collaborated on writing Julia hi
chicks yeah okay she Leone but the Lord
was not comfortable with James anti
really anti-english sentiments okay okay
so it's built up yeah right okay
in the early 1790s Scottish businessman
were tired of high English taxes and
tariffs and the American experiment is
in full swing so Mary's kicking ass yeah
well I I think wow the milks turning
yeah
Irish republicanism was threatening the
English hold in Ireland okay and in 1792
James published the political progress
of Britain which is strongly influenced
by Jacobin ideals of the French
Revolution so the Germans are the
biggest body of the guys in the French
Revolution they're really hardcore okay
so they're the hardcore dudes a lot of
beheading sure that sort of thing sure
sure
but the guillotine guys yes so they're
they're gaya teens yes they're super
right so you I mean there's a lot of
different way that's use now but like
they're considered sort of radicals at
the time sure to the other radicals okay
leftist radical little over so it
attacked the British his new pamphlet
attacked the British colonial
and tried to reframe the story of the
British expansion it was all about class
warfare and anti-imperialism okay quote
since the Norman Conquest England has
been governed by 33 sovereigns and of
these two-thirds were by a hundred
different action deserving of the gibbet
of the gibbet I think that I bet fibre
khakhra give it is where you hang a dude
in a cage oh and the dude dies jeez a
lot of pirates were gibbeted you hang
him in what do you mean you just let him
starve in a cage yeah you put him in a
cage and that's just that's his deal man
he's done that's a nightmare yeah yeah
not great it's not a great way to go and
that's public it's public it's also
today used in public schools in Oklahoma
with students they put students in
Oklahoma in cages yeah they have to be
over ten I think between Tannen there's
a height requirement
no they just it's just giving is bad for
kids under under ten yeah you know in a
damage them but you can give it kids
up to 18 once you once you're at a high
school I think there's any giving what
it's true you talking about okay
England and Scotland were anxious about
nationalist writings because of the
whole French Revolution thing so James
was investigated sure the leftist
Scottish writers he trucked with
including Lord garden stone were
infiltrated so they sent in guys to you
know spy and and then in January 1793
James ran off to Dublin instead of
appearing in court to testify about his
pamphlet okay these panties a pretty
prophetic pamphlet redwoods are big he's
dropping a lot of pamphlets
yeah he's haven't liked his Dylan era I
mean yeah yeah he then made his way to
Philadelphia in May Lord garden stone
Dinah be doing any pamphlets while
you're in town don't know if I've good
time I'm working on a couple different
poplars I'm working on a concept
pamphlet right now something different
you know like from the perspective of a
character from space you know but
prog-rock
yeah that's a good one yeah yeah so Lord
garden stone died soon after he left his
set of a broken heart what Lord garden
stone died of a broken heart
well even really liked him I guess oh he
died of a broken heart because of James
yeah did garden stone sounds like a
little bit of a I'm gonna leave well
done no super Sun garnets throw a little
shade of garden stone Philadelphia was
one of the oldest cities and ports but
with a flood of recent immigrants so
it's right so it was the first urban
melting pot in America sure and with it
nativist sentiments were rising ok new
immigrants and first-generation
Americans were not treated well by those
who had lived in America for a while ok
so this is when Philly formed yeah James
saw a place for a fellow like himself
quote it was the happy privilege of an
American that he may prattle and print
in what way he pleases and without
anyone to make him afraid so he's like
the Banksy of pamphlets he is that's
exactly what he was the Banksy of
pamphlets okay James has offered some
jobs writing Forex Irish radicals and
one he wrote a short column urging the
United States to stay out of the war
between England and France okay which
you know you know about that yeah yeah
convinced them James is a pacifist who
thought war was inherently destructive
unless it was against bloody England
yeah he called those who were for war
barbarians okay and suddenly James was
in the middle of a debate between the
Federalists and the Republicans the two
forming political parties okay we always
get to yeah yeah that's how it works
best
hey the illusion of option the two sides
were arguing over how to set up
a democratic representative government
the Federalists Federalists were rich
had more power and believed in
centralized federal government for
banking and tariffs ow
they were isolationist when it came to
the war between France and Britain the
mostly southern rural Democratic
Republicans so that's what they're
called back then Democratic Republicans
were into states rights and sympathetic
toward the French Revolution because
they no likey England right some of them
were huge Anglo phobes okay the
Federalists were happy to do deals with
Britain
so James didn't like her trusts humanity
much sure it was a big fan of
the whole human thing sure he was always
just gravitated towards birds it's
completely hello fellas hello ladies
you're the only ones you understand me
and how horrible the bloody English are
oh stop it you guys all right I'll take
my shirt off but only for a second kiss
you well alright I'll give you a little
kiss
so he's a huge contrarian is I'm
supporting any group in political or
economic power okay he was not big on
centralized government he couldn't
really get defined the idea of democracy
either cuz he was was a human he's just
one of these days and crazy missin
bright okay
being a contrarian James opposed the
Federalists who were in power can the
contrarians form a political party my
god have you at best it would be huge it
would be everybody that's kind of the
Republicans right now I think we could
find a lot I bet you that would be
pretty much everyone on social media
yeah so a yellow fever epidemic hit
Philadelphia in 1798 in between 10 and
15 percent of the city died okay another
20,000 fled to the countryside oh my god
the people in the countryside like now
oh dude a bunch of us a [ __ ] dying
back there we got to come here for a
little bit yeah leave my fence alone
don't tip that cow twenty thousand it's
a lot yeah
about tents a lot of tents that's when
you get into ten business you know I'm
talking about tents newspapers closed
and James had less work he started
writing in support of the Democratic
Republicans and got a job as a
congressional reporter for the
Philadelphia Gazette okay it's a Jacobin
paper what Jacobin remember the guys
from France oh yeah yeah okay gotcha
at this time congressional debates were
not recorded by the House or Senate okay
so for reporters were the only way the
public can learn about what was being
discussed we're so close to that again
so they had they gave them desks in in
the debate and right so they're so
they're in the in the room and they got
desks near like off in the corner or
whatever okay so so pants down soon a
number of papers were publishing
verbatim reports of the debates but it
wasn't easy for the reporters to hear
them and calendar complain some
congressmen spoked too softly so some of
it is inaudible so they're trying to
whisper their way around and at the same
time they're dipping pens in an inkpot
to write what people are saying so
that's just like real op so yeah it just
looks like a dolly yeah it's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] fests what can you to bring it up a
little bit bring it up can you talk
louder I agree with it first guys hey
okay
as we were saying prior no yes you're
coming an Inc boy it's foolish [ __ ]
what you're a foolish I'm writing this
down
what so the way this worked is since
there's no official stenographer was a
stenographer who is just an ink
stenographer then but so they reporters
so they'll have biases right oh it's not
like it's not refer it's guys who
actually have biases who are now
recording stuff boy that must be tough
to find the truth in and so they would
then write their official versions which
led to them making guys some guys sound
good some guys sound bad like a guy
right perfect so right after starting
the job James was accused of Mis
reporting an incident in the debates on
Madison's revolutions he said that one
rep had called another rep a British
agent okay so that guy the congressman
soon had the nickname British agent
very creative we are literalists and a
lot of people were accusing him of being
a spy now he was because of the name
British agent because of what the that's
what James wrote sure so he was burned
in effigy in his home state of South
Carolina in Charleston where they have a
store for effigies what kind of person
is he mean I'll walk you through here I
can show you a bunch of different
options as far as your effigy goes this
pissed off James Madison who was a
federalist who was pushing for better
trade relations with Britain without
really knowing it James had created
conflict and Congress that played into
the hands of the Democratic Republicans
okay so the time if you can imagine
congressional amendments were proposed
just to try to embarrass the other side
sure I can imagine that no you imagine
that happening in in government yes
sounds a little juvenile members of
Congress did not want these official
records kept because much of what they
were doing when they're trying to
Barriss the other side was hyperbole and
lies okay good lord I mean
the 1790s have been described as the
gutter age of American reporting live my
god Thomas Jefferson said quote hold our
beer defamation is becoming a necessity
defamation is defamation is becoming
necessary of life in so much that a dish
of tea in the morning or evening cannot
be digested without this stimulant even
those who do not believe these
abominations still read them with comply
compliance complacence no it's not an
betray a secret pleasure of the
possibility that some may believe them
though they do not themselves so it's
just all he's saying it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] right they found an audience to
buy the [ __ ]
of course Jefferson was super into the
abominations himself right while working
for The Gazette James was also secretly
working for a Republican paper called
the Aurora okay it was one of the most
important political journals in in the
new nation of America and was very anti
federalists okay in the Aurora James
exposed Alexander Hamilton's economic
scheme as favoring the wealthy and
entangling us so he's he's kind of
pointing out the [ __ ] of Hamilton
and the fact that he's working with
Britain too much and and undermining
people because he's wealthy you know
right okay so Jefferson's undermining
the wealthy like sorted like he does a
musical sort of like undermining the
commoners for the well it's gonna be
harder to Ryan yeah
Jefferson then in turn was attacked by
Hamilton Papers okay and at this time
one man's land there was another guys
fact what Jefferson was upset about
Hamilton would call plain fact each side
in the debates of early America thought
that they were the hero and whatever was
said was worth it because the stakes
goddamn it what damn it TMU so James is
very against something
the Jay Treaty which was being debated
and put together which many thought gave
rights to British traders while not
giving us traders in the advantage okay
it's like a giveaway if you can imagine
this like a giveaway to the wealthy
mm-hmm
old-school sure Hamiltonian economics
relied heavily on the British system and
critics denounced it as being anti
Republic okay so James say James was
opposed to the treaty yes yeah so it was
the same sort of thing that he had seen
when he worked at the scene in Scotland
right right so when the Jay Treaty was
passed Alexander Hamilton so obviously
he wrote about it another Republican
writers wrote about it and they attacked
Hamilton so when the Jay Treaty was
passed Alexander Hamilton was stoned in
New York City in front of City Hall as
he tried to explain the treaty to a
crowd wait because because it passed
yeah and already there's been such
fervor had been created and people hated
it so much Alexander Hamilton was
stopped don't pelted with stones you
don't hear that too much no you don't
and look that's in the musical Hamilton
no I don't think I don't think there is
that part yeah yeah they don't talk
about that in history books when
Hamilton was stoned but people also
thought that you the promise stones were
everywhere yeah and the truth is you can
try to get rid of stones as much as you
want but until you can cure mental
illness people are gonna want to throw
stones so get rid of all the stones you
want people with mental illness they're
still gonna it's a mental illness
problem it's not an access to stone no
it's not access to stones now some pen I
know some people say you know you
shouldn't be able to get boulders so
easily right well look I mean you know
what I mean boulders are there so you're
gonna get them yeah anybody can get a
boulder yeah you can get well you go to
a boulder show you can buy a boulder in
the parking place the treaty says that
we can have all the boulders we
thank you yeah exactly yeah so so that
people also didn't think that that they
they should be allowed to debate a
treaty in in like private in this
chamber they felt like that was like
some sort of betrayal against the people
so that was another reason he was stoned
right like you can't talk about a treaty
in private hmm
normal closed-door sessions they call
him in so James then attacked George
Washington okay
he claimed Washington was no better than
a monarch disregarding the will of the
people
James helped make the
democratic-republican God disappeared he
so he helped he helped sort of form the
arguments for the Democratic Republican
Party and he but he was also very
belligerent and uncontrollable at the
same time yep you can imagine he went
beyond went way beyond other Republicans
in attacking George Washington writing
quote if ever a nation was debauched by
a man the American nation has been
debauched by Washington he's got bloody
horse teeth in his bloody hey the only
thing he complete his bloody porridge
with animal teeth he also warned of
Washington's quote phallus designs
against the liberties of the people they
scoff phallus designs I've seen him he's
got a whole room devoted to him I think
they're nice sexy don't think that's
fair yeah what is your deal why are you
what you're doing why you're here what
you talking about gonna put on a
nightgown what it's the middle of the
dam we're in public okay don't think
he's not Scottish I'd yeah no way very
well are you late I'm from all over
awful nightmare even though he was very
opinionated James did try to try to
accurately report what he saw much
bloody infuriating so he used two ways -
new brand new ways they were considered
very unusual of conveying unspoken
meaning shouting agent so to
editorialize he would put an observation
in parentheses like an action that was
taken by he's writing a one-act yeah
kind of say write what the person said
and the parentheses did say what the guy
was doing so he's giving me so sort of
subtext yeah or he would say what the
guy said previously he would compare him
it's nice yeah and then sometimes you
put words in italics to emphasise strong
pronouncements and this people would bug
[ __ ] like they didn't know what was
happening because they'd never had
actually any one sort of display
inflection or like tone or anything like
that before so oh my god it's perfect
they know they were little half circles
around a bunch of it again and then it
goes to the Slayer
okay I'm gonna lay down and when I get
up I want the paper to be regular again
when I just want to go to bed until the
papers normal oh my god words are
slanted yes somebody slanted it and
somewhere in those half circles and
guess what some irregular words happy
took blah so 18 dead well I was worth it
and what can only be described as cuts
to himself the publisher kept with it
and people came around with the italic
stuff but he was eventually fired from
the Gazette in 1796 sorry James you
changed a lot of stuff but your words
landings just a little too weird
crazy boy so his wife and three kids
that arrived in Philly in 1795 a four
son Thomas was
born in Philadelphia James work became
less reliable and then he became the
target of slander in newspapers and his
family slid into poverty cool from 1795
into the until the election of 1800
James and his fellow militant Anglo
phobic Republicans wrote prolifically
about Hamilton economics okay they
bonded over their distrust of the upper
class most of them had been born abroad
James became very close with a Scottish
merchant named Thomas leaper I can jump
it they drank together they wrote
together and they bonded over the idea
of a future United States not dependent
on foreign economic interests okay
freedom a [ __ ] fact that he liked a
little free market like could you bloody
actually even fathom what that would be
feeling it's [ __ ] crazy it'd be
unbelievable let's have another drink me
please cause I imagine it to you and I'm
talking about like yeah one not chill
currency like something that's late you
nothing no no more bonds no more land on
the ship just a place where you know
perhaps everyone just you know plants
their own seeds and picks it on fruit
like a like a garden like no having a
sharp eight man
oh just pinch a man oh I'll be bloody
keen on that I would be oh I'd be bloody
nice I'd be oh my imagined have like a
bloody plum tree yeah let's just see
like something's changed my league
like I'm really famous yeah well you got
one chief okay okay I've got a bunch of
birds we can fire you imagine free
market so
James had always believed in equality
and believed in taxation to get it so he
then became a rabid he became a rabid
rabid Democrat which at the time wizard
turned me into a bunny it's compared to
being
Jagga been like I said right the JAGMAN
sure James saw the US as an aristocratic
government where a certain class would
hold power as opposed to representatives
of the rest of the population
it's amazing to call this so early
because at the beginning right like
because we talked about it it's like I
mean I guess it's it is like a
propaganda method in a sense but it's
like we talked about like that time this
time so wistfully it's like oh when it
all made sense and we even look back and
we're like well they couldn't have first
seen assault rifles but here's somebody
who's just right now just like hey it's
already [ __ ] yeah it's [ __ ] up
what we're doing is funny it's a bad
path to chart yeah people knew it right
away right so they started talking [ __ ]
about the country's checks and balances
saying it kept the government from doing
the will of the people is now radical
views alienated him from moderate
Republicans Jefferson Hamilton were both
members of Washington's cabinet right so
they're so they're they fight a lot but
right in there right of course yeah well
they're in the Brotherhood and they
carried out their disagreements through
the newspapers okay
Hamilton WWF yeah no okay Hamilton
complained to Washington about the
attacks Jefferson then wrote George a
letter denying any involvement in
newspaper writing as nothing to do with
that he's lying of course sure having
written articles himself anonymously
haha who's this Jefferson Thomas
character Tommy
jealously Tommy Jefferson Tommy huh when
George Washington left tomerson 22 left
the White House in 1796 he warned
against the quote spirit of party that
would turn the disputes between men like
Jefferson and Hamilton into a permanent
state of combat sure you mean one that
is completely unresolved so we just stay
in a at least pendulum at least no one
saw this coming now by the end of his
administration in 1796 they were about
30 Republican Papers compared to about a
hundred and twenty Federalist ones they
have all the funny money okay Jefferson
begged James Madison to attack Hamilton
and print quote nobody answers him and
his doctrines will therefore be taken
for kin
fest for God's sakes My dear sir take up
your pen select the most striking
heresies and cut into pieces in the face
of the public okay
Jefferson then met James Callender they
met in a Philadelphia print shop
James now had the backing of Jefferson
Jefferson promoted whoops
Jefferson promotive loves the pamphlets
he wrote so Jefferson's now permeates
James's via retweeting James at this
time public figures expected and had
privacy when it came to their personal
lives okay the writer was crazy enough
to print personal stuff he used the
subjects initials instead of their name
what does that matter people couldn't
figure that out or is this before people
knew what what initials were demon-like
italics D T [ __ ] his daughter it was
pretty well known in some circles that
Hamilton was having an affair with Maria
Reynolds he's present he's 36 yeah your
cousin he's 36 she's 23 she married her
businessman husband was invested in the
continuation of foreign trade okay James
published his pamphlet history of 1796
in installments in the spring and summer
of 1797 in it he exposed the affair
between Hamilton and Maria Reynolds okay
he dropped full names okay all righty
not giving two shits okay James believed
only virtuous leaders could ensure the
vitality of their public which is how he
justified airing the dirty laundry Wow
okay so he's page six in it yeah [ __ ]
yeah okay and the evidence he presented
was compelling
James labeled the husband as a pimp whoa
and said since that was the lowest of
all human character traits
Hamilton's deals with him made him lower
than just being an adulteress so he's
saying besides just having affair he's
worse than a because because this guy
the husband figured it out and there was
a lot of [ __ ] going on
uh-huh was not just a guy [ __ ] so his
wife it got really weird sure right well
there's always that as a [ __ ] saddle
like there was a um pardon [ __ ] saddle
wait what does that mean will you put a
lady in the saddle and you've like a
hanging saddle and uh Oh like a swing
not much really yeah
yes x-wing I call it a saddle because I
like horses okay so here's what I'm
gonna recommend we'll cut this out let's
just power head how do you even get
there you are such a horse pervert plow
ahead uh
you know what that makes me think of
stable things you know they sleep laying
down if you have [ __ ] him right
so Hamilton confronted James Monroe who
he believed had leaked the information
okay
Monroe said he had nothing to do with it
I'm not the leaker Hamilton then
insinuated Murrah Monroe was a liar okay
probably by just calling him a liar yeah
yeah and then Monroe Monroe called him
within a scoundrel and challenged him to
a duel god this duel stuff it escalates
so quick - [ __ ] you're a liar no I'm not
I want to kill you let's try to kill
each other house Tuesday so right but
the duels over today and Aaron Burr
calmed things down between the two men
weird hilarious ah irony yeah guys guys
that would be insane what are you
thinking so James insinuated that
decisions Hamilton made for the country
were influenced by his dick and that he
was corrupt okay he didn't say that but
I put that in modern no no I get that
yeah I don't think that was in any he
used the term ha dick a lot though keep
reading in August 1797 Hamilton
responded with his own pamphlet gonna be
a sad one like when in
it's called the it was called yeah I
like to [ __ ]
no so
in it he denied improper dealings so
he's saying the financial [ __ ] the
corruption stuff is a lie okay but he
did confess to getting an armed with
Maria okay and proved he had been a
victim of blackmail by James Reynolds
because of the affair
so James Reynolds found out and did
blackmail so but has the victim so he's
right well he's saying I didn't do he's
saying I didn't do deals with right I
was right you are you saying basically
on the business business ethic side my
dick got me into a predicament I don't
have low morals it's a hot argument so
response peddler so instead of working
with James Rosen being Krupp he was
blackmailed Hamilton had paid over
twenty four thousand dollars into Mitch
today's money to this guy that's nice
it's [ __ ] crazy
it's a nice chunk Republican papers
respond to that by saying that Hamilton
was trying to legitimize adultery okay
sure sure sure yeah James put on out
another pamphlet on the affair and
Hamilton's corruption in 1798 called
sketches of the history of America he
wanted to make sure Hamilton would not
be President and the corruption was
never Oh the corruption was never proven
the scandal subsided a bit though the
Republican newspaper attacks were on as
they tried to discredit all Federalist
policies and say Hamilton couldn't be
trusted by his wife so how could the
country trust him
Wow you ever heard that argument well
never so James is becoming more and more
notorious and the Federalists wanted his
scalp so the Gazette of the us quotes in
the name of justice and honor how long
are we to tolerate this scum of party
filth and beggarly corruption worked
into a form somewhat like a man to go
thus with impunity do we want to answer
that now
a long way the article in the Federalist
paper finished by saying James deserved
to go to the gallows oh yeah no boy
should see no put him in the gibbet or
whatever give it
publisher william Cobbett was James
calendars opposite on the federal side a
federalist side okay
he went after James and accused him of
selling his ideals to the highest bidder
and of chasing patronage and I had sex
with James Reynolds I'm swinging I won
I'm scandalous ah oh no hey this guy I
thought you were kicked out of no no no
no no no no no no COBIT was slandering
James character and his beliefs quote a
little mangy Scotsman who has a
remarkably shy and suspicious
countenance it's like he's trying to
give a dog away loves grog wears a she
wears a shabby dress and has no hat on
the crown of his head I'm not to mention
he doesn't wear a hat he's in a dress
I'm not certain whether he has ears or
not he leans his head to one side as if
he had a stretch and goes along working
his shoulders up and down with evident
signs of anger against fleas and lice
methinks he's in the Thriller video I
got it yeah there's a visual component
oh it worked
James life was now falling apart he fell
into poverty and had to move into a
poorhouse okay his wife then died of
yellow fever
then Kabat revealed that James had been
anonymously publishing political tax in
the Aurora Emily people were livid James
was now not just in legal danger but
also physical danger
well Jesus James claimed his house had
been broken into and his family
threatened twice by wannabe assassins
okay or but the assassin ninjas yeah
assassins don't come in and then just
threaten well I mean maybe they got
scared off by the dog gonna just let
this go away or back then they also
would use poetry against or some guy
comes in and he just says to James's you
know he just says the James he's like
it's a beautiful family be a shame if
something happened to their father and
then he's gone and I'm just gonna sketch
a couple years later yeah yeah yeah
that's it thanks dad
disgrace good yeah disgrace it
impoverished James left Philadelphia for
Virginia on foot in the summer of 1790
well I think I'll walk it good boy
the time when you feel like alright well
I'm gonna walk for four months like what
he was too scared to go in a carriage
cuz he thought it would be walk why cuz
he thought that people were people
people were looking for him so he
thought that if he was in a carriage he
could be found easily so yeah yeah no
definitely take the slow public route of
walking without any coverage for sure
it'd be safe
he left his four kids behind who were
put into the care of his old friend
Thomas leaper and as he headed south he
learned that he was still being hunted
outside of Leesburg Virginia
he was arrested drunk and loitering
outside of a distillery okay so things
are good he was charged with vagrancy
okay he made to his destination which
was Sunday you don't have a hat on oh
that's crazy and illegal if I made to
his destination which was senator
Mason's home in Virginia James
complained to Jefferson that Republicans
owed him for what he had done okay he
also whined that he was quote bolide and
stared at as if I was over na Souris
okay right and I am in danger of being
murdered without doors alright so what's
happening now I guess a lot of people
like back then carried doors around shut
up
yeah no no
very common said was almost like having
a hat where's your door
what oh he's saying there that he's
afraid of - he wants to be behind doors
he finds company doors what I think he's
saying I think he's saying that he needs
a place to hide out
I think I think what everyone's trying
to murder him I think you'd say if
you're saying doors you're like I like
doors what doors just like really ideal
rate named Jefferson London $50 and
encouraged him to keep writing which
helped him guess oh my god
James Thomas male friend her bloody
walked here oh I thought it's gonna get
married on the way I need to buy a bunch
of doors
I need safety I need something I'll take
a nice leap right now but to be returned
a friend finally the war in place I'll
tell you it's like having a blanket on
my shoulders after a big cold for a
while
well here's $50 keep writing oh no I'm
saying like I'm going to die if I'm not
careful [ __ ] down right well uh you
know here's $50 you should write you
know what I always liked where your
pamphlet I love your writing your
pamphlets are great great Hey so the
thing is my wife is really weird about
having someone who ever wants to murder
crash with us yeah you know kind of one
of these people and she wears the pants
in the relationship
alright but well when you got a rough
draft of that pamphlet don't be afraid
to come on over just about every place
I'll take a look-see at her so Jefferson
helped him get on his feet until he was
hired at the Richmond examiner James
started writing his next pamphlet the
prospect before us it was called man it
is so reminiscent to me of albums
totally throw is like what is this Punk
for a baby they says go be my Sergeant
Pepper pamphlet
my sergeant pamphlet
[Laughter]
this pamphlet was an argument against
President Adams parental warning and for
president Jefferson okay so well I think
at this point Jefferson is vice
president at this point you this was
back when the he wouldn't be on the same
party so he people would vote for either
so you could have a like it was today
you could have a Democratic president
and then a Republican vice president oh
right right is the top to right that's
it
people would just vote people would vote
for your vice president you'd vote for
your president you separated oh but I
thought I thought at one point it was
like you who ever got the top two amount
of the hello think so I might be wrong
now you might be right
so James then published some claims in
the paper which resulted in a near riot
as people tried to drive him out of
Richmond boy so this guy is just a
bridge burner yeah James was terrified
and wrote to Jefferson saying he wanted
to leave newspaper writing and begged
Jefferson to get him a job as a teacher
or a door maker door someone who creates
doors and has access to a lot of
daughters Scott idea that door oh I'd
love to live in a house shut doors
Christ Jefferson just sent James money
for his advance copies of the prospect
before us can't wait to read it
keep us all posted here he also wrote a
letter praising James literary ability
to stir up the public and expose
corruption dearest Thomas I fear that my
ratings have finally got me in a lot
more trouble than we've ever anticipated
at this point I think the freedom of
expression is something I must cast off
for my views when expressed properly
elicit violence from fork please
I need your help whatever you do do it
now help me can't wait to read the next
one amigo
love you stuff xoxo Tommy James was back
on board after getting this letter and
kept working on the prospect before us
they wrote many letters back and forth
though Jefferson never signed his oh
interesting sincerely James then
publishes attack on Adams future
historians he predicted quote will
inquire by what species of madness
America submitted to accept as her
president a person without abilities and
without virtues a being alike incapable
of attracting either Tennyson tenderness
or esteem
James called Adams quote a hideous
hermaphroditical am a Fredette ik am
afro do tickle character which has
neither the force and firmness of a man
nor the gentleness and sensibility of a
woman this is getting a little sad yep
Jefferson was a thrilled which was odd
for a man who was friends with Adams and
James Callender was kind enough to send
a copy to President Adams okay
interesting now say what's this fruit
however did achill and yet even though
I'm a hermaphrodite achill person I lack
the compassion on either side well this
is scandalous writing and hot and
something about it's making me wanna lay
down and tingling that's it I'm going
under the blankets with no pants on for
a little while and I'm gonna put my
touching gloves on they did use touching
gloves that's right I've got a set of
gloves I use for touching their the
fabric the Lord can't see your hands in
invisible hand fabric now for
masturbating wink wink
the pamphlet also laid out what James
believed were the roots of corruption in
the United States system of government
okay
the Federalists scrambled to deny all of
his points with almost no evidence this
really weakened their reputation and
James pushed Jefferson as being the only
true candidate to vote for the
Federalist returned fire spreading
rumors that Jefferson with an was an
atheist from whom the god-fearing people
would have to hide their Bibles okay
he's coming for your Bible yeah that's
the same thing but you're gonna do that
with guns but back then it was box your
Bibles imagine open a hotel drawer and
not seeing the Lord's work in the second
one that's why I joined the National
Bible Association that's right from our
cold dead hands President Adams then
came after James calendar in July 1798
Congress passed the Sedition Act which
criminalized making false statements
that were critical of the federal
government oh boy
so what are we t-minus two years we
wrote the legislation in a desperate act
to stop Republican newspapers that were
ruining them Republicans then how
because it was a constitutional
overreach that wreaked of a monarchy
Republicans worried the Federalists
would make the Senate or the presidency
a lifetime position no Federalists
worried the lies coming from Republican
papers would undermine the country
completely everybody's right just before
the election on May 21st 1807 years
after arriving in America James was
arrested under the Sedition Act Wow the
trial was incredibly unfair and not much
more than a mockery the judge was a huge
Federalist partisan and wanted to lock
James away the jury was packed with
Federalists Jefferson hired him three
good lawyers but he was convicted
sentenced to nine months and given a
$200 fine okay the judge said an attack
on Adams made quote an attack upon the
people themselves nope
at least at least this doesn't ever
happen
nope in jail James kept writing entitled
one new chapter more sedition Oh God
Jesus he's dropping more sedition now he
just drops edition it's [ __ ] amazing
he's just so he's just such a [ __ ]
curmudgeon what what man for sedition
what am i dating about sedition for my
next edition Republicans called
Republicans gather around James Kasich
so they're they're backing him out okay
and in the end
Jefferson wins the presidency okay I had
a lotta because this right this stuff my
back first James celebrated quote hurrah
how I shall triumph over the miscreants
that's an actual quote so he keeps
writing to Jefferson yeah it's about to
get sad right yeah so he keeps ready
Jefferson but getting my letters Tom
what's happening over there
Jefferson is not responding yeah so
James worked on the prospect before us
volume to a defense of Jeffersonian
politics okay so when he was released in
prison after the nine months he's about
to come at Jefferson eventually right
yeah well he expects to reap the
benefits of all of this [ __ ] health
care for Jefferson hey where's my room
well of course my bindle stiff need a
shower before supper what we haven't huh
Jefferson pardoned him and he pardoned
all the others convicted under the
Sedition Act but he distanced himself
hey James openly asked for the two
hundred dollar fine to be given back to
him okay and for President Jefferson to
appoint him postmaster in Richmond okay
so he wants a [ __ ] job sure he wants
and he wants the cash back that he paid
there's a [ __ ] I got party I should
get the money back [ __ ]
Jefferson just ignored it okay
now that he was in power Jefferson did
not need James James was pissed
oh is it for the time he wrote to
Madison quote oh I now begin to know
what ingratitude is but James was just
too much trouble he was unpredictable
and despised by many and he wanted to
change the entire Constitution and be
rid of parties so that obviously doesn't
work for the Republicans or the yeah
right
it's a uniting thing yeah James went to
DC and instead of meeting with him
Jefferson sent Meriwether Lewis to meet
with him oh yeah Lewis would later go on
the Lewis and Clark expedition okay
small town James threatened Jefferson
saying he had letters that they included
to attack Adams okay Lewis gave James
fifty dollars as hush money yeah but
nothing sobered up James Callender like
revenge here we go he went back to
Richmond and got a job with a centrist
paper called the Richmond recorder here
we go
this paper lamed Federalist James
started the work hi I'm Stephen Baldwin
James started the work of tearing down
the Republicans he attacked gamblers and
duelers and slave owners who had
children with their slaves while
pretending they did no such thing
as upper crust Virginians he then went
after Jefferson here we go riding
Jefferson had always known about James
writings and supported him financially
oh boy this is very similar the only
Hamilton published all of these articles
in his paper and accused Jefferson of
being behind exposing Hamilton's affair
she's
Jefferson wrote a letter to Monroe quote
I am really mortified at the base
ingratitude of calendar it presents
human nature in a hideous form it gives
me concerned because I perceive that
relief which was afforded him on mere
motives of charity may be viewed under
the aspect of employing him as a writer
perhaps I mean I was just giving him
charity I was dying him to write more
[ __ ] to get me elected charity cash
it's called a slush fund dummies
Federalist and Republican papers began
to attack each other Republicans now
attacked their old attack dog
James count okay one wrote that James
wife had died from an STD quote on a
loathesome on a loathesome bed with a
number of children all in a state next
to famishing while calendar was having
his usual pint of brandy at breakfast oh
my god okay so they're just painting
some syphilitic woman dying on a bed
with kids with their ribs showing
surrounding her while he's down there
like and then James Callender
went nuclear Oh No in September 1802
unpublished a report about Thomas
Jefferson's affair with his slave Sally
Hemings [ __ ] it's go time
he used the racist language of the day
in his writings the story spread like
wildfire
like the syphilis his wife died this was
a quandary as the Republicans had just
spent years saying Hamilton was not fit
for office because of his affair uh oh
my god
yeah me Jefferson just ignored all the
claims but James kept writing about it
and the newspaper subscription grew his
writing was more popular than ever but
he began to having an ongoing fight with
the paper's publisher the publisher
accused James of sodomizing his brother
wait black campus
sorry what just happened to this story
what is going on wait sorry the
publisher of the paper that James is
catching fire from is a bit of a Croma
jan towards James because he claims that
James sodomized his brother - James is
working for this Federalist paper sure
but then he starts to not getting along
with the publisher and then it turns out
that the publisher says James sodomized
his brother the newspaper business is
weird it's weird
reporters are weird I'm not gonna let
you run with the lead because you
sodomized my brother quit [ __ ] my
brother come on let me just remember
that this story's got teeth I'll tell
you what James I like your gumption but
I've got to tell you every time I look
at you I just think about that time that
just sodomized my brother you're on the
crime beat oh come on what are you
talking about that's disk work he
[ __ ] liked it he liked it let it be
honest part of the problem here is that
Nev always wondered what it would be
like he was also cautious there an
expert do we have follow-up so we have
nothing else about that we have no idea
we just know that he accused minimizing
okay so we've got an unclothed sodomy
file in the story well that's why rocker
files covers it made sure he was also
constantly threatened by Republicans so
James started to drink stories of his
behavior while drunk began seeping out
according to one story he stumbled into
his hosts bedroom so the place he's
living in in the middle of the night and
demanded that his servant be whipped
okay it's quite a survey okay I'll just
go back to bed then so then James
refused to write anymore we went on a
four-week bender oh that's a log under
on the 17th of July 1803 James was seen
wandering John
in the out-of-town okay later that day
his body was found floating in the James
River in very shallow water the irony
the medical examiner proud some dead by
accidental drowning and he was buried
the same day years later DNA would
determined that Jefferson had children
was Sally Hemings and of course Hamilton
was shot by Aaron Burr yeah yeah he was
like isn't this weird that we're now
dueling boy
so what are we so first of all fake news
it turns out is part of the foundation
of our country it's not [ __ ] new it's
there's always been fake [ __ ] news
yeah yeah it is it is insane what
happens when you deny people access easy
access to truth how how easy it is for
people to give up on trying to find out
what's real [ __ ] crazy but that is
the first that I mean that is like that
this is like the inception of TMZ yeah
basically he's the first guy that went
you know super yeah that just went for
it it was just like there's literally no
rules there's no off the record because
no freedom of its you know you get free
speech so let's [ __ ] knock this [ __ ]
to the wall yeah go full [ __ ] on got
the first the first there the weirdest
the best some might see it would be
great to get him into this world now and
be like thank you happy nickel but I
like how what he the one thing he did
was call out how our system of
government is [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah right
yeah during the during the time they
were putting it back on as like this is
when everything was perfect though was
it yeah it's like no everybody was still
like the same we were I mean yeah we
were all just like now this is [ __ ]
its monarchy probably yeah help rich
people Christ well I mean what do we
expect the what's amazing is how don't
do that what's amazing is how this
country was founded upon leaving the
monarchy
yeah and we're just inching towards the
monarchy King Trump yeah great well
that's been the dollop podcast yeah we
saw in cars we sign cars oh I should
point out I was on the scale our
brothers podcast called dumb people town
oh you were on last episode enjoy that
had a lot of a lot of fun with them and
yeah they're good fellas they're funny
fellows good guys and that's a good
podcast on people town and that then
that dvk character to that Daniel
thinker okay yeah you're going good guy
though
great alright let's go to Denny's thanks